marking the Age of Aquarius here yes sir
so happy to be here
season 10 we're in the thick of it it's
thick but I'm feeling skinny it's really
exciting in a world full of nines I
expected it to be something that you
can't expect you know all of the past
drag race alum their biggest advice to
me was expect the unexpected hello it's
me Valentina Valentina came to New York
for a show and she pulled me aside and
she like aquaria I know you might be
going through something very fun soon
and I just want you to know that you
need to have fun with it and stay happy
let's dig into this season a little bit
okay we started right out the gate we
had the whole miss cracker thing right
people called clear your cracker before
cracker query it is like always like the
hugest biggest elephant in the room
crack ahead of her in the tank
competition it's about to go down
trust Oh believe me I to this day blame
Bob the drag queen for this he posted a
picture of us both out of drag and was
like these two heifers look alike then I
get to drag Grace and when I walk into
the workroom you know everyone's asking
about it and after a while after 50
million questions you're like wait you
know I am so mad at this this is not
acceptable which is not the case you
know you got like all shook up in your
head got it I'm saying all this stuff
about this stupid freaking yellow dress
that wasn't even like a good example of
it but we moved on yeah we spoke going
forward I want to see you do you really
want the competition and go far I
certainly want to go further than you
but let's just like try to do our best
us whether it's by accident or on
purpose or whatever yeah at the stage we
are in now who's your biggest
competition left well I think Eureka is
definitely the largest competition but
my biggest competition honestly at this
point right now Miss vixen
I think it's kind of funny that the
Vixens best drag look was composed to
have a wave that she didn't even bring
from home for buzz drag race let me
inform you all to season two when they
were absolutely all the Katia [ __ ]
what I said was like a compliment in
season two so it's just like can't win
do you did you feel misunderstood by the
other girls at all yeah but um I
realized that I don't always come off
the way that I think that I come off I
worked so hard even done a summer would
be jealous what would you say the
biggest misconception about you is I
would say the biggest misconception
about me is that I'm pretty it's just a
lot of makeup know that I'm like kind of
stuck-up and cold I think a lot of the
issues that arose at Drag Race was more
that I was just in the mindset of do the
job
get in get out in doing that I think I
forgot that I was supposed to you know
make friends be personable be like a
human that the girls can relate to and
that y'all can relate to and yeah pretty
much that we solve a lot of season left
oh my god I'm so excited to watch at all
what's gonna surprise us about the
second half of this season well I think
I'm gonna be equally as surprised
because lord knows if I was there to
wrap things up here I'm gonna say two
words to you miss Angie Miss fans miss
Angie
[Music]